well the tile is Joe's bed-stuy bomb
shot we cut heads and it's sort of like
him the gangsters Jean Ron it takes
place in a barber shop in the
bedford-stuyvesant section of Brooklyn
New York and it involves the numbers
racket is it hard to be it's very hard
but I think that being students it was
easy for us because when you're in
school just sort of like and sort of
like a little bit of heaven because you
have access to equipment whereas if you
were independent filmmaker out in the
world you don't have the equipment
because uh I shot my film for a month
and I thought I had to rent that
equipment if I hadn't been in school the
rentals was it came out to $70,000 but
since I was in school I had the
equipment to shoot to film I want to
make four for a month and you get a
whole lot of other stuff on his side so
that's why I chose the route become a
filmmaker to go through school because I
don't have anybody in the industry to
gonna get me in and film school was the
only right new house when you win a war
like this it makes you Simula jit
because for the most part being a
student filmmaker when people in the
industry hear student films they run I
mean there's a bad stigma connected to
student films but er this award makes
you kind of like similar jit and will
maybe get your answer your telephone
call answer it's over it's been good
there are a lot of people no matter what
you do they're gonna tell you whatever
you do it stinks
you know they doubting you know they
down in your work and I never always
believed myself I knew I had a good
script and uh when you believe that when
we're shooting 18-hour days and actors
and actors about to quit and anything's
going wrong that belief keeps you going
and then when you get recognized for it
it makes that sweeter plus you get it a
week out here in LA and it puts you up
at the Beverly Hilton and you get to
meet a lot of people in the industry so
was it's been like icing on the cake
what is it that you'll remember
doing it the hard way
well hopefully I always remember the
hard work that it took you know that the
film when people see a film they really
don't realize the hard work it took
because it took like a year and a half
time the ideal to the finished answer
print and I when you're outside filming
can really have no concept of the hard
work they just dingus you know they just
disappeared but it's not like that I
really don't think that I should myself
be doing the same thing everybody else
could be doing Anna that's one reason I
think I got this award because a lot of
people in film schools my class my
experience they chose to make horror
films and but everybody could see that
in the theater and I'd try to do
something special and it worked out this
time
[Music]